[Music]
on this Tuesday night a group home
operator accused of over-medicating
children in care I felt like a zombie at
one point as we confront the
psychiatrist who wrote those
prescriptions all that is nonsense okay
at the time Global News investigates
defending the use of emergency powers to
stop the Convoy protests it was on the
brink of being completely ungovernable
if not already by then why Canada's
Public Safety Minister believes what the
government did was justified plastic
pollution solution there's not nothing
similar a BC team's groundbreaking
alternative to styrofoam
and this guy needs a bigger fish tank
the giant goldfish caught in France
[Music]
National with Donna freezing good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight with a global news
investigation a report into Ontario's
child welfare system that was quietly
released by the Association of
Children's Aid societies last spring
shows three-quarters of kids in group
homes were taking mood altering
psychotropic medications in 2021. these
are kids who have been abused neglected
orphaned or have mental health or
behavioral issues tonight we hear from
whistleblowers from a for-profit group
home company who say kids are being over
medicated instead of getting therapy to
deal with their trauma Carolyn Jarvis
has our top story tonight
when Tashina Burnett and Jamar Morrison
entered Ontario's child welfare system
what they needed was compassion and help
healing did you get help no I got
medication at group homes run by a
for-profit company called hats off they
and other kids say they were over
medicated oh yeah very overmedicated
prescribe serious behavior-altering
drugs how many of the kids in the home
were on medicine everybody
every single kid Global News spoke with
more than a dozen former workers and
kids in care who expressed serious
concerns about the overuse of medication
prescribed they say to deal with things
like depression and anger these kids are
supposed to be angry we've concealed
former workers identities for fear of
retaliation because they had trauma they
had trauma and they missed their
families
hatsoff says it has a full-time
psychotherapist on staff and kids
receive weekly or bi-weekly therapy
which may include trauma therapy CBT or
cognitive behavioral therapy addictions
counseling or art therapy
but kids and workers we spoke with say
they only had occasional art therapy
which didn't help in all the homes that
I've been to I haven't seen a single
instance of actual traditional
counseling who they did see was a
psychiatrist on retainer with hats off
for years Dr ramakrishna sura Panini
that was him Sarah Panini he was the
essential piece to hatsoff's foundation
without him you wouldn't be able to keep
all the kids drugged and medicated
former workers and youth say
appointments were brief and the amount
of medication almost always increased
your supervisor tells you that this kid
clearly is depressed you should go to Dr
Sarah Panini and tell them he's having
this this and then based on that that
five ten minute interaction the doctor
signs the prescriptions and you're good
to go you left these appointments with
Dr Sarah Panini and suddenly you were
being told now I'm on antidepressants
and a whole bunch of other crap
medication is a good social control
mechanism and it works it keeps them
almost comatose and while some kids
objected to taking medication they felt
they had no choice you don't force them
to take them but you make it very hard
for them to refuse like you're not going
to be allowed Electronics we're going to
take away Lego if tomorrow we're gonna
go do something well you're not gonna go
hatsoff says it would never direct a
staff to force a resident to take
medication or reprimand them
The Fallout of the mounting medication
say former youth was disastrous I felt
like a zombie at one point I was
sleeping all the time I was Moody sad I
even got like heavily suicidal at one
point to the point where I actually like
tried to hang myself in the closet and
you think that's because of the medicine
100
hats off which declined an on-camera
interview said in an email that it
relies on Health Care Professionals and
it would be beyond the scope for it to
question or interfere with a treatment
plan including medication did you blow
the whistle on this to anybody half the
time to your supervisors but it doesn't
go anywhere it's part of the system to
run this whole thing the drugs are
integral to this as for Dr sir Panini
Carolyn Jarvis with global news we met
up with him outside his office in
Waterloo several former group home youth
from the hatsoff group home chain
contacted us because they expressed
concerns about being over medicated
after coming to see you all that is
nonsense okay why is it nonsense it's
done get out well some of these you said
you get out that's all I know what sort
of tools tool to give a youth who comes
see you to deal with trauma
today Tashina only takes one medication
while Jamar doesn't take any
meanwhile hatsoff continues to use Dr
sura Panini as their Consulting
psychiatrist
Carolyn Jarvis Global News
tomorrow in part three of our
investigation we seek accountability and
uncover a secret draft report that shows
the government knew of concerns at hats
off years ago
Canada's Public Safety Minister says it
became virtually impossible to enforce
the law on downtown Ottawa during the
so-called Freedom Convoy in February
Marco Mendocino testified today the
public inquiry into whether invoking the
federal emergencies Act was warranted he
said he believed the nature of the
protest and the challenges to restore
Public Safety met the threshold for
invoking the ACT
we were concerned about whether or not
the blockade might Target the Prime
Minister this was a movement that that
in some cases was prepared to attack our
Democratic institutions to force uh
change
Amanda Chino also told the commission
events at the Border in Coots Alberta
earlier this year played a significant
role in influencing the government's
decision to invoke the ACT David Aiken
reports
in my opinion this was an illegal
protest that was National in scale that
opinion held by Public Safety Minister
Marco Mendicino appears to have been
widely held by Trudeau's cabin and some
of his most senior advisors that's
according to testimony given in this
final week of hearings by the commission
reviewing the government's decision to
invoke the emergencies act last winter
and ultimately forming the opinion that
we needed to invoke the emergencies act
one of my main concerns was the
inability to enforce the law adjacent to
critical infrastructure
that critical infrastructure the
government was worried about was not
just border crossings and highways but
Parliament Hill itself these are federal
Democratic institutions
um but we did not have total
jurisdiction over that space
[Music]
going for Mendocino was the situation at
Coots Alberta where undercover RCMP
officers discovered weapons among those
blockading the Border there four
protesters were arrested each charged
with conspiracy to commit murder among
other things and even though the Coots
blockade was resolved before the
emergencies Act was invoked on February
the 14th Mendocino said the RCMP
operation at Coots was what he called a
threshold moment I was extremely
concerned that this had reached a new
height of both urgency and emergency a
lawyer for the Convoy organizers wanted
to challenge mendocino's opinions but
that lawyer Brendan Miller got kicked
out of the commission room for arguing
procedure with the judge overseeing the
processities
Miller then claimed the whole process
was unfair set up to blame former Ottawa
Police Chief Peter SLO for the events
leading up to cabinet's decision to
invoke the emergencies act they have
tried to turn this entire proceeding
into an inquiry about the failures of
Chief slowly
as opposed to actually about the
invocation of the emergencies act more
cabinet ministers testify Wednesday
including Justice Minister David lametti
David Akin Global News
Ottawa
a former Army reservist who crashed his
truck through the gates of Rideau Hall
in Ottawa has been granted day parole on
July 2nd 2020 Corey Hearn rammed the
Rideau Hall Gates armed with two
shotguns in a semi-automatic rifle he
abandoned his vehicle and went looking
for the Prime Minister and what a judge
called a politically motivated armed
assault intended to intimidate Canada's
elected government during a 90-minute
armed standoff he told police he was
angry about gun laws and covid-19
restrictions last year Huron pleaded
guilty to seven weapons-related charges
he was sentenced to six years his
application for full parole was denied
his day parole is conditional on getting
a job undergoing counseling and taking
his prescribed medication
Canada's Chief electoral officer
appeared before a government committee
today to discuss suspected foreign
interference in Canada's 2019 federal
election Stefan Perrault says he was not
previously aware of any specifics
regarding alleged campaigns of
interference by Beijing prime minister
Justin Trudeau also says he did not have
any information on federal candidates
receiving money from China sources have
told global news that Canadian
intelligence officials delivered
sensitive briefings warning Trudeau and
select members of his cabinet about
allegations China was running
sophisticated operations Eric Sorensen
reports
the Prime Minister repeated that in his
security briefings he was not told about
funding of federal candidates
specifically by the Chinese government
there has never been any information
given to me on the funding of federal
candidates by China Trudeau did not
address reporting by global news that
sources say a clandestine election
interference network was covertly funded
by Chinese State entities in the 2019
federal election and that the Prime
Minister was briefed in 2022 by Canadian
intelligence officials on these stunning
allegations of political interference
schemes Canada's Chief electoral Officer
says he's not aware of Beijing
interfering Beyond global news reports
I've not received any reports regarding
specific instances of non-compliance
with the legislation or or specific
instances of Chinese interference in the
election was the Prime Minister briefed
yes or no the opposition says the
government is not being transparent
about just what the Prime Minister was
briefed on the government is avoiding
specifics they were taking action to
combat attempted into foreign
interference Mr Speaker beginning with
our national security agencies who
conduct investigations separate sources
with knowledge of the 2022 intelligence
briefs told Global News funds from the
Chinese Consulate in Toronto allegedly
facilitated by a Toronto businessman Wei
Chung Yi totaling some 250 thousand
dollars was transferred first to an
unnamed Ontario MPP and a federal
candidate staff member Wei Chung Yi
denies the allegations from there
sources say the money was distributed to
members of a clandestine Network
intelligence says the network was
comprised of at least 11 Federal
candidates along with 13 campaign
staffers according to the intelligence
some are wittingly affiliated with the
Chinese Communist party some are not
sources say the network includes
liberals and conservatives Justice
Minister David lametti suggested the
need for caution in revealing too much
publicly obviously there's a need for
transparency but there's also a need for
our security services to protect their
sources to protect their their their
the methods in which they gather
intelligence all of that is important
and so and so we need to act prudently a
former thesis officer worries that
intelligence officials haven't
adequately briefed the Prime Minister
Prudence is not necessarily the bad
advice for the general public but
definitely if you speak to the Prime
Minister you need to be for coming Juno
Katsuya says one thing Canada must do is
to toughen Canadian laws to crack down
on money transfers that could constitute
interference in Canadian elections Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
hundreds of Canadian gymnasts have
shared their stories of abuse as part of
a study into the safety of sport in
Canada some of them spoke in Ottawa
today trying to get the intention of
politicians and Sport leaders in the
country
for the past five years I've been kept
in silence as a former gymnast and abuse
Survivor a Judicial inquiry is
so needed for
athletes like all of us up here who left
the sport
broken instead of enriched
study is being led by Ontario Member of
Parliament Karen Vecchio she echoed the
athletes calls for a Judicial inquiry
adding that now is the time to get
involved in order to protect the next
generation of athletes from facing the
same kind of trauma
excitement is building as Canada's men's
soccer team prepares to kick off their
first World Cup match in 36 years head
coach John Herdman delivered some good
news ahead of tomorrow's game the entire
team is healthy and able to play
coach Erdman says the Superstar Striker
Alfonso Davies is fully fit and will
play the 22 year old was hurt in a game
a few weeks ago Canada has to contend
with Belgium and then Croatia and
Morocco if it's going to advance past
the group stage
there was a stunning outcome to one
match today Saudi Arabia beat Argentina
2-1 it's one of the greatest upsets in
soccer history Argentina scored three
goals in the first half that were all
ruled offside and then the Saudis scored
twice in the second half to stun the
soccer World Argentina had won 36
straight games until today Saudi Arabia
is rejoicing tomorrow has been declared
a public holiday to celebrate
searching for a second night coming up
the rising death toll after that
powerful earthquake in Indonesia
Canada has announced more sanctions on
Belarus over its support for Russia's
invasion of Ukraine foreign affairs
minister Melanie Jolie says 22 officials
and 16 companies are being added to the
list Jolie says the lukashenka regime is
allowing its land to serve as a
launching pad for Russian attacks on
Ukraine and enabling human rights
violations today Jolie met the country's
exiled opposition leader in Ottawa
Svetlana Tico noshaya says she's hoping
Canada will put economic and political
pressure on the regime
Canada have been standing for free and
Democratic builders for many many years
and
your support gives us hope and energy to
move forward
the head of Ukraine's National Energy
company calls the damage to that
country's power grid colossal Russia has
been targeting power generating
facilities with missile strikes the
Energy company says practically no
thermal or hydroelectric stations have
been left unscathed repairs are underway
but it's a massive job rolling power
outages are expected to continue through
the winter
Rescuers in Indonesia are working
through a second night to try to find
survivors trapped after Monday's
powerful earthquake many of the dead and
injured are children more than 22
thousand buildings collapsed when the
5.6 magnitude Quake struck early in the
afternoon when kids were in school
officials say more than 260 people have
died 150 are still missing authorities
are scrambling to provide shelter clean
water and food for the nearly 60
thousand people who have lost their
homes
carbon pricing controversy ahead the fee
being applied in parts of Atlantic
Canada next year
thank you
the federal government is expanding its
carbon pricing scheme rolling it out in
three more provinces Nova Scotia Pei
Newfoundland and Labrador as Ross Lord
reports much of the money will be
returned in rebates but provincial
governments are still disappointed by
the decision
while forcing its carbon pricing plan on
three more provinces the federal
government is trying to accentuate the
positive more families will get the
climate action incentive checks more
often let's make up for the fact more
consumers will be paying extra at gas
pumps until now the fuel charge was
applied in Ontario Manitoba Yukon
Alberta Saskatchewan and Nunavut
consumers in Nova Scotia pei and
Newfoundland and Labrador will start
paying more both at the pumps and to
heat their homes starting next July for
others BC the Northwest Territories
Quebec and New Brunswick have their own
pricing systems Nova Scotia calls the
measure punitive yeah a 14 Cent increase
at the price of pump in in Nova Scotia
it's going to have an impact Nova Scotia
Premier Tim Houston says he fought to
the end against a measure that will hurt
rural residents and will not reduce
emissions in his Province the feds
insist most Canadians will get more
money back in rebates than they spend on
the fuel charge frankly I'm I'm baffled
by Premier Houston's position just as
the government prefers to focus on
rebates the federal conservatives are
fixated on the fuel charge happy Canada
Day
today your gas bills your heating bills
and your grocery bills have just gone up
that's the message from liberals to
three Atlanta Canadian provinces the
controversy leaves voters with plenty to
consider there's a sense of whose
message is going to resonate more
there's a palpable sense of fatigue with
the liberal government and so if polyev
doesn't overplay his hand I think he's
actually in quite a good spot the
government is changing the way it
delivers the payments instead of
including them an annual income tax
rebates checks will be mailed out to
Canadians four times a year another step
in highlighting the positives of a
controversial policy Ross Lord Global
News
bio foam breakthrough next the BC
research team making advancements to
replace styrofoam
[Music]
try fitting this in your fish tank this
is carrot a carp koi hybrid believed to
be the second largest ever caught carrot
lives in a lake in France and weighs
more than 30 kilograms that's about 67
pounds it took this British angler more
than 25 minutes to reel it in he posed
for some pictures and then released it
carrot was put into the lake about 20
years ago and just keeps growing but
rarely gets caught
in British Columbia a group of
researchers has teamed up with a local
first nation in a partnership aimed at
tackling one of the world's biggest
polluters it's a new packing material
they hope will become a commercially
viable and environmentally friendly
alternative to styrofoam nithu garcha
explains
these UBC researchers are turning wood
waste those are the
with revenues slashings from the
forestry into a biodegradable foam in
Hope it'll one day replace styrofoam
which can take 500 years to decompose in
landfills my dream is there will be no
more styrofoam packaging floating and
also floating in the in the landfill in
the ocean so it will be all everything
will become the barrel foam the
potential pollution solution a
partnership with wet so would in First
Nation developed three years ago when
both groups met at a BC forest Ministry
event after the indigenous Community
expressed concerns about wood waste
created from pine beetles and wildfires
we needed to find a way to use
everything we have in the forest rather
than you know just piling up and burning
it what they've done instead is grind
the wood waste into a fiber and using
biodegradable chemicals turned it into a
foam which then goes into the oven right
now there's nothing similar in the North
American Market the researchers say
they're confident about that process of
turning BC forestry waste and eventually
even agricultural waste into this
biofoam product so a key question now is
whether it's a viable commercial scale
alternative to styrofoam the production
cost here in the lab is what fifth of
the marker the retail price of the
styrofoam he says the biggest cost is
sourcing the wood waste from the forest
they're looking for investors to create
a pilot project by next year to test out
the technology at a larger scale
probably you can start to see this
packaging material in the market maybe
after three three or four years the
Project's intellectual property is
shared by Zhang's team and what so it in
First Nation getting clean water and
housing
education and health and wellness and
making sure we're you know putting
Revenue to those uh four pillars a
lab-grown plan with big potential to
help the planet
Global News Vancouver
that is global national for this Tuesday
I'm Donna Friesen tonight's here Canada
is this bird's eye view of Toronto
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
foreign